bill and I are here at the United
Nations week really talking about these
goals that the UN set several years ago
to try and make the world a more
peaceful and prosperous place and so
we've created an event called goal
keepers which is really to talk about
these goals and what's achievable
between now and 2030 so that people
really understand them and know that we
actually are making progress towards
those goals but that progress is not
inevitable
what goals so these goals were set by
the United Nations and they are around
having a sustainable planet making sure
we solve climate change making sure we
bring down maternal mortality women's
empowerment bringing down childhood
mortality those are the goals the
sustainable development goals set by the
United Nations 169 Nations today we
create heroes of ordinary people with
extraordinary stories and how does your
organization help to try to achieve that
and how you doing well we are in
partnership with many many governments
around the world the UK government
included France Germany Norway many
African governments the Indian
government to try and work on some of
the very specific goals that is we work
on bringing down maternal mortality we
bring down childhood mortality one of
the greatest things that have happened
because the previous goals set by the
United Nations the Millennium
Development Goals
is that really childhood mortality that
is the number of deaths of children
under the age of five has been cut in
half since 1990 in half that is huge
progress as a world so our foundation
works in partnership with many
governments and other other NGOs on the
ground to create new vaccines and
deliver them or to deliver for instance
bed nets I was speaking to one of your
colleagues earlier who was pointing out
to me that the population in places like
Nigeria is going to be higher than what
it is in the United States right so one
of the things that bill and are
highlighting today at this goal keeper
session here's United at the United
Nations Week is that we need to really
pay attention to the youth population
and the growing number of youth on the
continent of Africa and it hangs in the
balance
we help them lift themselves up
there's unbelievable potential there for
them to change their countries and their
continent but however if we don't make
the investments the world has made in
the past around vaccines or malarial bed
nets or other tools then they're gonna
stay in poverty and we're gonna have
more people in poverty than we've had in
the past and so we want to make sure
that the world goes towards the youth
potential one of the huge things that
our foundation is behind along with the
British government and many others is
making sure for instance that women and
girls have access to contraceptives
they're 214 million women asking us
around the globe for contraceptives and
if we give them the tool that many women
in the UK use are the tools that women
in the United States use they can then
choose if and when to have children and
if they space the births of their
children their children are likely to
grow up more healthy and the family is
more likely to be wealthy we know that
from great research over time how are
you judging success what is success for
the organization in countries like
Nigeria it's up to the [ __ ] in Africa
well we've looked at a whole number of
things around these these sustainable
development goals we look at these
nutrition getting better for children
that is our and we can measure that by
saying how many children are stunted
well the stunting number is actually
coming down around the world one of the
countries that's done the best on
nutrition programs is Brazil they're
stunting rate was cut dramatically in
the last 20 years we can take the
lessons from Brazil and we're applying
those in places like Nigeria Ethiopia is
had a steady decline in stunting they're
the second largest population on the
continent of Africa so we look at all
kinds of issues of measures we look at
stunting we look at contraceptives in
the hands of women and used we look at
malarial bed nets delivered and how the
deaths are coming down from that so we
have a whole host of indicators that we
follow as well as those countries follow
I mean they're the ones doing the work
they're the ones reporting the data and
I think our job as philanthropists and
as government as high-income governments
is to help take the tools in the
innovate
from our countries or the tools and
innovations that they're creating in
their own countries and make sure those
come forward and get into everybody's
hands what do you think about what the
president said his view was that
countries that are less fortunate than
the United States will not be
benefitting from foreign aid unless
they're they offer more respect to the
US how do you feel about it well luckily
the president proposes a budget and
Congress disposes the money and I think
we have a pretty enlightened Congress
about our four and eight dollars and we
have not in a very long time as a
country tied those foreign aid dollars
to specific statements like that and I I
believe that you know you have to spend
four and eight dollars wisely and you
have to spend them where the greatest
disease and disability exists and so I
that hasn't happened in the past in the
recent past and so I'm still encouraged
one of the things that I think this
administration does care about is that
the money's actually spent well and
there are discussions you can have from
from a business perspective of you know
if you look at the data these are the
places you ought to invest he was openly
laughed up at Unga wasn't it yeah how
does that make you feel as in America
I think we need to have really good
leadership in the world and I'm
encouraged when I see people like
president McCrone showing forward
leadership to me that is what the best
of democracy stands for and so those are
the types of words I'd like to hear from
our US president that we are not hearing
today
can we talk briefly about your children
sir today do they want to follow in your
footsteps so the thing that bill and I
have encouraged all three of our
children to do we have two daughters in
a sign-in date is to follow their own
dreams and their own potentials so
they're still figuring out what they
want to do we have a daughters out of
college a son who just entered college
and another daughter who's in secondary
school so we'll see what they want to do
what sort of support D I mean a
complement was it was it mr. Buffett who
said that he wasn't always that
Zuckerberg who said that he wasn't going
to leave any of his money to his
children he was going to they had to
continue on their own path and make
their own way do you do that with yours
so Lauren has actually changed a bit
what he's done with his own children
over a time and so I think those
discussions about money are actually
very private inside of a family and
should be kept that way but I will say
this bill and I made statements that the
vast majority of the resources that have
come from Microsoft will go back to
society and I think all the other
discussions about money one of the
things the kids and I talked about when
they were young is they did get an
allowance they had chores they had
allowance and our agreement was between
them and me they were never allowed to
tell anybody else what their allowance
was and neither was I because everybody
would think it's either too much money
oh my gosh the Gates kids get that much
money or that's all the Gates kids get
so I think money discussions amongst a
family should remain private inside a
family
what sort of choice did they have to do
oh my gosh they do dishes and take the
garbage out I mean things that other
kids do absolute Microsoft changed the
world do you see it
as nothing but a force for good I think
that the products Microsoft has creative
absolutely changed the world and change
the world for the better now any tool
that you can create can be used for for
good or not for good but yeah I think
it's been an incredible force for good
in the world you bet
you won't know there was a lady in the
United Kingdom who has young children
and she decided that she was going to
smash the iPads of the kids because they
were spending too much time on tablets
in the UK it's a big deal at the moment
what about here in the United States
well one good thing is an iPad is not a
Microsoft I'm sorry more power to you
get my point
yeah I get your point so I think that's
the role of a parent right when I was
growing up my parents had rules about
how much my sister and I my brothers got
to use the phone
right and we had two phones in our house
two phones in our house you know at that
long line and we had to decide on the
telephone cord who got to take it in
their room and for how long but we had
rules around that I wasn't allowed to
speak on the phone all night long to my
friends and so I think it's up to
parents to have rules around their kids
that are age-appropriate for their
children around technology you wouldn't
just put a computer in a child's hands
right away
I do see parents making that mistake but
I think there are good if you talk to
parents who've been through this journey
or are living it now the ones who are
doing the best or putting rules around
technology at different age appropriate
levels and then opening it up over time
it's like any tool you have to learn how
to use it what's a good day for you
a good day for me is when I have a
little bit of quiet time in the morning
get up early get some exercise in
particularly outdoors the Seattle
weather's a lot like the weather in the
UK so I love what it's sunny and I can
go outdoors and exercise and then you
know getting time with friends and with
my kids and with Bill and then getting
to do the work that I love and this work
that we're doing around the world is
work that I absolutely love and how do
you find time to relax and what do you
do I read that you're a big fan of the
crown we are big fans of the crowd and
Bill and I don't move forward in this
series without the other one so if one
of us is traveling we have to wait for
the other one to come home so we did
that bill likes to play a lot of tennis
I play a little bit of tennis I like to
go jogging we like to kayak together
there's a game you might not have heard
about it's becoming more popular in the
United States
called pickleball - racquet sport and we
play that together we have a campaign
Sky News are running at the moment which
involves us wanting our leaders
political leaders to have a debate like
you do at you have lots of debates
leading up to the presidential elections
we don't not have that in law in the
United Kingdom at the moment do you
think it's a good idea that political
leaders should have to face the public
and be questioned ahead of an election
campaign definitely I think it it's good
part of the democratic process you get
to see how a leader thinks on his or her
feet you get to see what they're
passionate about in terms of their
answers and it gives the chance or the
for the public to really see the leader
in action before being electing the him
or her good to talk to you thank you
very much thank you thanks for your time
thank you absolutely fascinating stuff
still to come on the cable show live
from New York City for you're going to
be speaking to the Foreign Secretary
Jeremy Hunt about everything from
President Trump brexit and the progress
of negotiations to release Nazanin cigar
a replica
[Music]